Oh
[Music]
to Angela
but I shan't
flighty so high-level feed the power
what then
Romilly from guys and dear friends who
are tuning in today I mean not in them I
came to see a brother called hurry hurry
hurry hurry Nia hurry hurry
that's it hurry me ages behind me we
just came here just shooting a little
video for Iman channel and we just
popped into the little herbal store and
over there we came across a lovely
lovely individual a lovely lady and I'm
not just saying this because she's here
because what she did and what she said
it really really touched me that I
wasn't even here to do this I understand
you know what I'm not gonna miss this
opportunity I'm definitely gonna come
and do this video and meet her because
it really touching we're gonna find out
for us of Isla I know you know I'm very
well thank you how are you young with
funky remarks just about yourself yeah
one thing that really touched me is the
fact that obviously we're trying to give
something we're 'no Serene's condition
and reads a bit of money what made you
like obviously one thing that we need to
point out in today's conditions that
were living in sadly there's this whole
Muslim and non-muslim thing going over
the far-right group and it's extremist
et cetera and it's dividing us and it's
putting us like were different but the
action you did there really mind just
blew my mind away because you don't you
don't know him and the fact that okay
look we do look was him but that meant
absolutely nothing to you like if it
wasn't even like Doogie I'm trying to
think why why what because he needs some
help and that's why we're here
and my belief system is that if everyone
helps everyone just a little yeah then
we can all make a difference doesn't
matter color creed race religion that
shouldn't matter you at all if you need
my help I'd help you and I'm sure that
if I
she'd help me in 2% and that's a message
that we really need to put out there
because like I said before to me it
doesn't matter you know you being a
Muslim or an ism you're a human being
you know if I saw you someone trying to
harass you or whatever look I'm not
gonna be that goal she's not a Muslim
neither the way you like you treated us
and you say oh I've been Muslims and
that is so beautiful and it's so so hard
to find in today's time so I think
individuals like yourself are a gem to
be honest and I really really thank you
for the way you have treated us because
sadly in today's time we are looked down
upon as you know terrorists they don't
like us they hate us and that's not the
case you know it's all the thing to
divide and separate out there if we're
dividing separating all the things are
going on that we don't get we don't get
involved in but to me it's about and I
want to say thank you as well for her
Eamonn Holmes had to come and share
their story with me to trust me with you
as well because you know I was only in
the shop but I believe that everything
is structured I believe that the
universe brings people together at
certain times for certain reasons
so for me and only that that you opted
of sympathy you know but you said that
use in connection with not Stevie what's
to be done and the Evening Post and even
imposed yes yeah so they saw the fact
that you know not only obviously in
falaqa show sympathy etc but you took it
to a step further and said you know what
I know people that can help you guys and
obviously the the not not TV and yeah
what kind of help can be kind of bring I
think is I I have sort of appeared on
there
you talk about just in general getting
that information out there and getting
that awareness
we've got memories I've got four
children okay so we have four children
and eldest son had cancer thank goodness
and thank everything he's fine
and her Ian's going to pay yeah but it's
having that positivity and knowing
yeah that's thing one thing as well guys
like the positivity was mind blowing
like even when Kareem obviously when he
said hopefully that's something in as
Muslim to be sure inshallah means God
willing you know obviously not you
didn't know about I use that look Kareem
it's gonna be okay you concentrate about
this and it was just wow it's just a
positive it amused me like I was like
wow such a profound way of thinking and
not only that guys what is so much more
amazing is the fact that sister ila yeah
of course the style especially yes
sister sister sister
ila basically as we was going to get the
camera cuz I really wanted to interview
this she automatically started like you
know those people at the shop yourself a
few shops just right next to him they
started to raise at how much not even
counted yet the way that I looked at it
was when we talked about hate to dance
and past because when you put something
out there that you need a hundred eight
thousand pounds that's an immense amount
anyone to raise but you think about
180,000 people you care most of them can
give a pound yes so to break it down you
look at how that can help and when I
mentioned I want to do a collection my
staff had donated their tips we've got a
couple of hands in customers were here
it doesn't even matter how much is you
know even if it was 10 pence the [ __ ]
the intention behind that is so lovely
that then that Tim pence
because for me it's all about energy so
while everybody in here is get sent in
hurry thoughts and wishes it has to have
an event it has to know that he's not on
his own and his family's not on his own
and we can all do something to help even
if some you know really small amounts we
dope now hundreds thousands - interpret
okay you're so positive I I wish I have
that in my life anyways guys what I want
to do is for everybody that's watching
at home Muslim one was them in
Nottingham if you're not seen them or if
you're passing by do come to Iowa's
coffee shop and check out the tea and
the coffee in Java but also that there's
gonna be maybe a box we're not going to
have a collection here I'm looking for
people who can do something as well to
help help us do collections anybody
who's got any sort of talent passion
whatever it is you don't have to be an
expert in your field but just care about
someone so then we can do some things
well I went to Jerry's I've liked Kareem
and I was there to get me some details
about the condition so when people come
in we can talk about it we'll learn a
little bit more and then we can get more
people involved and hope that to grow
until we've got me mad so guys
definitely come and check her out even
if you're walking past even if you've
got nothing to give I think you're given
commonly see in ila it's gonna change
your mood a bit and also put a smile on
your face so Muslim non-muslim come and
see last words for maybe pickets out
there who make us feel like we're
different we're not the last words that
you I feel sad
I feel sad for them that they don't have
that live in their heart because when
you are a person that is focused on that
something has had to happen to you to
make you so sad and I would really feel
sorry for those people not in an
arrogant way not in a you know not in
any other way but it's so powerful when
you love when you give that love and
receive that love it's like today I've
been accepted hareem's family and
they've shared things with me and I feel
honored tonight to be able to help and I
just think people who can't do that for
whatever their reason is inside and if
anybody wants to talk to me come see me
about it could have talked to me you
know if we can open up in London I wish
he was definitely one call my wife and
see but then again just a message to
people out there like I said this
behavior doesn't just come from
non-muslims you get this one Muslim
individuals as well that trying to make
it seem like non-muslims are different
no we're not different you know as if we
work as a community we can achieve a lot
of things and once you keep that in mind
either thank you very much may God bless
you and I genuinely admire your
positivity I mean attitude I really
really thank you so guys do come and
check out either T so guys hope you
enjoyed the video besides enjoying the
video obviously we want to take a action
and that is obviously as you guys know
we are trying to raise money for her ins
condition donate as much as you can even
if you can't donate share it and also
brothers and sisters specifically
sisters if you maybe the maximum area or
you're visiting there or in the
surrounding area please go and visit
sister Ida
at her tea shop it's an amazing place a
little place go and see a show some love
you know thank her for her support and
the things that she's been doing for us
you didn't even know us that I said
before go and see her and also that is
the main center where people can go and
donate and also have a bit of maybe tea
or cup cake whatever it may be so guys
please donate to the link below I'm
gonna put the address of the tea shop do
go visit her you know make me buy some
flowers whatever it may be
thank you for watching and I bless you
guys and also I want to thank our
sponsors halal sweet company do check
them out as well and order some hello
sweets for yourself